china has abandoned its controversial
one baby policy allowing couples to have
two children the first time in decades
that decision by the authorities of
Beijing well bring some significant
changes to the demographic makeup of
China at least that's what the Communist
Party is hoping for let's get the views
now Reggie Littlejohn whose founder and
president of women's rights without
frontiers she joins us live now by Skype
from San Jose and California Reggie
Littlejohn very good to see you and the
original idea was to slow down the
booming population in China back in the
late 70s and early 80s but what was the
effect for China well the effect for
China has been a two-fold demographic
disaster number one China does not have
a young population to support its aging
population which is the reason they've
moved to a two-child policy and number
two they have had suffered the sex
selective abortion of baby girls and
there are approximately 37 million more
men living in China today than women and
this has been going on for decades this
aging population this gender side issue
and so now they're finally taking some
action but it's not enough so basically
apart from big tough for men to find a
bride in China I mean it is basically
skewed the whole of society hasn't it it
is completely scooted because you have
situations where you have four
grandparents to two grandparents to one
child and so they do not have a young
population to support their elderly
population and part of the result of
this is that they are seeing an epidemic
now in the suicide of the elderly so the
thing I really want to get across to
your listeners is that the fact that
China has moved from a one-child policy
to a two-child policy will not and
forced abortion in China you still have
to have a birth permit for the first
child you still have to have a birth for
the second child and if you don't you
can be subject to for supporting and
forced sterilization so not everything
with this change of the Communist Party
rules not everything in the family
garden Rosie but presumably a slight
improvement for millions of young
couples I'm very happy for the young
couples who are going to be able to have
two children but even those couples if
they don't have a birth permit for each
of those kids they're still going to be
subject to forced abortion so we have to
keep the pressure up it's not enough to
modify the one-child policy it has to be
abolished all coercive birth control and
China must be abolished in essence it is
state-controlled fertility isn't it
absolutely and they do things like
having cervical checkups on women you
have to go through a huge process to get
a birth permit if you don't have one you
will end up with a forced abortion
unless you're wealthy enough to buy your
way out of it which most people are not
so this is what people don't understand
this is not a suggestion this is
coercion there's also forced
sterilization forced contraception so
all of this is a huge human rights
violation and it needs to end completely
not just be modified Oh Reggie
Littlejohn from women's rights without
frontiers thank you very much for your
input on the subject